When you think of Leonardo da Vinci,
you probably think of the Mona Lisa.
Leonardo da Vinci is one of the
most famous artists in the world.
But he is much more than that.
Indeed he never thought of himself as an artist.
When he sent a letter to the ruler of Milan
describing his strengths when he was looking for
work, he listed 10 different skills. And almost as
an afterthought, he mentioned he could also paint.
The reason his artworks are
so realistic and detailed
is that he invested much of his
time in the study of science.
da Vinci was born in a village near
Vinci, just outside Florence, in 1452.
The illegitimate son of a farmer’s
daughter and a prominent lawyer.
Although he didn’t receive any formal education,
his artistic ability was clear from a very early age.
When he was 15, he studied under the acclaimed
artist Andrea del Verrocchio in Florence.
When da Vinci helped Verrochio paint
an angel in the “Baptism of Christ”,
the story goes that his version was
so much better than his master’s
that Verrochio vowed never to
pick up a paintbrush again.
da Vinci was a notoriously slow painter
and many of his works were never finished.
Only about two dozen survive.
A drop in the bucket compared to other
artists. Van Gogh left more than 2,000 works.
da Vinci wasn’t just interested in how the
human body or nature looked on a canvas.
He wanted to know why they appeared as they did.
He was able to give the Mona Lisa
that mysterious look on her face
because he studied all the
muscles involved in smiling.
He devoted a lot of his time
to studying human anatomy.
If you wanted to learn about human anatomy
in the 1500s, there was no easy way to do so,
no medical textbooks and, of course,
no way to google search an image.
So he studied the only way he
could - by examining corpses.
Hospitals were keen to support his artistic
research and gave him access to cadavers.
He dissected over 30 bodies in his lifetime and
filled thousands of pages with
notes and detailed drawings.
If you’re having trouble reading this, it’s
because da Vinci had a habit of writing backward.
He liked to go from right to left. He was
left-handed. So some have speculated this would
have stopped his ink from smudging. His writing
can be read normally only if viewed in a mirror.
He probably wouldn’t have done so if he
had any intention of publishing his notes.
His depictions of the body are
beautiful. And for the most part,
accurate. So accurate that professors can
actually use his drawings to teach anatomy.
One of his most famous works
that perfectly illustrates
the fusion of art and science is the Vitruvian man
which depicts the proportions of the human body
according to Vitruvius - a Roman architect.
The man’s outstretched arms are equal to
his height, which is true for most people.
He was particularly obsessed with
the heart which he described as
a “...wonderful instrument
invented by the Supreme Master.”
Many of his medical conclusions about the heart
have turned out to be stunningly accurate.
He was the first to describe the heart
as a muscle, that it has four chambers,
and that the arterial valves opened and
closed to let blood flow around the organ.
He was also the first to
recognize coronary artery disease.
Around 1506, he witnessed a 100-year-old
man die suddenly. He dissected his heart
and discovered that his arteries had narrowed.
He deduced, this was what killed him.
He was far ahead of his time. Coronary
artery disease wouldn’t be described
by a physician until more than 150 years later.
It’s a mystery why he never published any
of his work. His notes were not discovered
until the late 18th century - more than 250
years after his death. Had they been known during
his lifetime, they could have had a profound
effect on the understanding of the human body
and, perhaps, helped physicians
find ways to heal certain ailments.
In the same way that he studied the body to
improve his paintings and then became obsessed
with anatomy, he studied plants to improve
his art and then became obsessed with botany.
He drew most of his delicate works with red chalk.
His sketches of plants were so accurate they
could have been considered scientific studies.
In the Study of the Star of Bethlehem,
the swirls of leaves are similar to the
movement of water - another one of his obsessions.
da Vinci dedicated a lot of time
trying to understand the flow of water.
Most of his 72-page scientific
diary called the Codex Leicester
is dedicated to the study of the motion
of water in seas, rivers, and canals.
Bill Gates bought it for nearly $31 million -
making it the most expensive book ever sold.
da Vinci also invented the lock that almost any
canal or waterway you visit uses to this day.
The lock was mitered - as in - two 45
degree angles meet each other at a point.
His contribution to engineering
extended from the waters to the skies.
Da Vinci sketched out this flying machine
that he called the Aerial Screw while he
was employed as a military engineer
by the Duke of Milan in the 1490s.
The device was meant to be powered by four
men who would push the four wooden shafts in
a circular motion. da Vinci believed this would
generate enough force to lift it off the ground.
Had he actually attempted to create a real-life
model it would have been too heavy to lift.
But the basic principles of lift-off provided
the earliest foundation for modern helicopters.
He also made sketches of a parachute,
speculating that if a person had a tent
made from linen that matched their
proportions, they would be able to
jump from any height without being injured.
Once again, he didn’t make a real-life model.
But a British skydiver did use da Vinci’s idea 500
years later, in 2000, and it worked, in practice.
da Vinci clearly had confidence in his own designs
and had done some mathematical equations.
He applied math to his paintings.
The Last Supper, one of the most
recognizable works in the world,
is a prime example of the use of the
mathematical principle of perspective.
Jesus is sharing a final meal with his
12 disciples before his crucifixion.
All the lines in the painting converge in
one place, known as the vanishing point so
that the focus is on Jesus. This was done
to emphasize the importance of Christ.
And he wasn’t afraid to try new things visually.
The traditional Florentine way of
painting was to outline an image,
giving it a very crisp appearance. Instead, he
perfected a new technique, sfumato,
which means “vanished” or “evaporated”
in Italian. It gets rid of hard edges
by blending everything without
lines or borders. The Mona Lisa
is a classic example of the use of sfumato,
particularly in the shading around the eyes.
He also began to experiment
with new materials for painting.
Renaissance period artists were moving away from
egg tempera paint - which was pigments mixed with
egg yolk and water to oil paints, which allowed
for more vivid colors and greater contrasts.
However, oil paints were complicated to
make and the quality fluctuated greatly.
So, da Vinci put on his chemistry hat and
cooked his own pigments in linseed oil at a low
temperature and added about 5% of beeswax which
prevented the paint from darkening on the canvas.
da Vinci’s art was a confluence of biology,
chemistry, engineering, mathematics, and physics.
He employed all these skills when France’s
King Francis I appointed him as ‘the
first painter, engineer, and architect
of the king’ when he was already in his sixties.
His final work was not a painting but
a party he threw in the summer of 1518
at his residence at theChâteau du Clos Lucé, the king’s summer castle, inCentral France, to thank him for his generosity.
There was a spectacle at the party where players dressed up
as planets surrounded by the sun and the moon.
da Vinci was the first to explain why you can see
light between the two points of a crescent moon.
He figured out it was due to sunlight hitting
the Earth and reflecting onto the moon
called Earthshine. This was an outlandish
theory at the time. Most people didn't even
know that Earth orbited the sun! He was,
once again, far, far ahead of his time.
When da Vinci passed away at the
chateau on the 2nd of May in 1519,
he left behind thousands of pages of
notes and drawings for future generations.
He may be best known for his art.
But clearly, he was a Jack of All
Trades and the Master of Them All.
If you’d like to master STEM
subjects, just like d a Vinci,
Brilliant can help and it’s FREE to sign up.
My sponsor Brilliant is a website and
app that helps you brush up on your math,
science, and computer science skills.
Take this lesson on the Insertion Sort
Algorithm, for example. If you've never
done computer science before, this can seem
like some pretty heady stuff. But on Brilliant,
there's no coding syntax needed — you just
move around blocks of code and get immediate
feedback on your results, so you can develop a
deep understanding of how this algorithm works.
There are no tests, it’s for all skill levels,
and if you’re feeling stuck on a problem, you
can read the explanations to find out more.
All you have to do to get started
is pick a course and jump right in.
There’s something for everyone. From
exercising your critical thinking
skills through logic courses to
learning about cryptocurrency.
It's FREE to sign up for Brilliant. And the
first 200 people who use my link will get 20%
off the Premium subscription which gives
you unlimited access to all the courses.
The link is in my description.
For Newsthink, I'm Cindy Pom